welcome to another episode of not too
deep hey this streaming award-winning
podcasts I'm your host grace and how big
the first and this is so thrilling this
is an episode that's so fun so I've been
waiting for this episode for a while
this girl is blowing up right now Elle
Mills she's an amazing youtuber an
awesome inspiring content creator she's
got um she's got that uh what do they
call it that she cares about her work
vibe to her which is very very
aspirational to me and we got the kind
of picker a little Canadian brain about
everything that she's been up to over
the last couple years
also um she just not to spoil with us
but she purposely peed her pants in
front of fans at playlist live and that
speaks to my heart tears of my
heartstrings and so I'm very excited for
you guys to take a listen take a look at
this episode not too deep with Elle
Mills hello wonderful beautiful uniquely
incredible listeners of the not too deep
podcast I just want to give you a quick
task if you don't mind in order for us
to get support for a show we need the
help of great advertisers and in order
to find these great advertisers we need
a little bit of help from you if you
won't mind going to pod survey comm
slash grace you can take a quick
anonymous survey that will help us get
to know you better
that way we can work with advertisers
that make sense for you plus once you've
completed the survey you can choose to
enter for a chance to win $100 Amazon
gift card terms and conditions apply
again that's pod survey calm slash grace
P OD s you are ve Y dot com slash grac e
thank you in events for your help
[Music]
we're here we're doing it we're doing it
live on tape with Elle Mills thank you
for being here boom for having me
course welcome not too deep I'm just
gonna get right into it your mom's hot
okay hi I was doing my my research and
clicked on your mom's Instagram like a
true pervert would yes and Wow
she's got she knows how to handle her
social media she's got a full brand it's
yeah I know and she liked it surprise
possession
how did that develop um I okay I do this
thing where I encourage people to get
into the social media world yes yes I
was like oh why not
yeah um instantly regretted it so she
has she made an Instagram I honestly
don't remember but she made it a thing
to roast my brother and I and basically
every post okay she knows that gets
likes and she's very very funny
yeah she's strategic about yeah I want
to take notes from her I wish that she
would create a TED talk on like how to
be a social-media influencer because
she's doing a great job I'm not gonna
show her this in this oh she's so got
stuff that's so funny okay so you're
incredible I'm like very inspired by
like what you're doing because I feel
like as an old Haggard woman in the
YouTube space I get I'm very much in the
middle of like a burnout moment for
myself creatively and I feel like you're
bringing this like completely new
refreshing energy into the space which
has been really really fun to see and
very inspiring to see but also it's very
stressful like you had a crazy year
ups and downs sideways is and all kind
of thing yeah how are you managing now
in terms of like the burnout I'd say
like um pretty decently yeah I'm getting
better um I'm not where I was when I had
that huge breakdown um which by the way
I cuz I you know when you put stuff out
there and you're trying to be authentic
and transparent and all of that
did you I can't imagine that you thought
that it would blow up as big as it did
or get as much attention as it did but
you just being honest about like your
brain yeah and it was kind of ironic
because with me talking about burnout I
became like the face being like it was
like bringing me place to place to place
to talk about it I'm like man this is
getting a lot yeah you're the poster
child for mental health now yeah but um
honestly in current this very month I
would say last month in November weren't
that great but um yeah 2019 has been
good good yes sir a forward momentum
positivity all that good stuff do you
feel since then after like sharing like
real-world feelings that now you have to
do that with every video yeah yeah yeah
that's stressful by proxy to watch that
happen yeah I I just feel like I was
talking to my friend Dodie yeah yes and
we're big fans of Dodie yeah she's been
a guest on the pod she's a lovely
charming little fairy of a human a
little Brit yeah a little British accent
yeah she was well wear it why was I
talking about
oh just mental health and like having to
constantly now reveal all your feelings
and show all your class I just done the
video about like weight loss and eating
yeah and I was sitting with her in New
York and she's like you've gotta just
talked about all your problems now have
no more videos to make I'm like no I've
cleared the roster done well we can help
you develop new problems if you'd like I
would love that yeah I feel like it's
never too late I'm a constant mess so
I'm very I have stage advice about how
to continue on the hot mess Express
track it's pretty fun and exhausting at
the same time okay so what's going on
with you this year like you've been
doing one year videos everyone compares
to John Hughes movies and it's a big
inspiration for yes yeah I do you want
to make movies like actual movies or do
you prefer like the platform of YouTube
I like the dream would be to make make a
movie yeah or do a project at least
bigger
YouTube yeah I would love to make a
movie that's what we're I'm trying to
work on right now cool it's just
different I'm not excited I'm like
totally oblivious to like traditional
media and like like I like things done
immediately i yeah it takes a long time
to make a movie yeah YouTube is spoiling
in that sense but you can have an idea
make it and then post it and then all
you have your instant gratification
right there exactly yeah so that's what
I'm working on right now definitely want
to get on that right away
cool well I'm excited for you also okay
going back to your family I got
sidetracked you and your brother have
this amazing relationship yeah have you
always been close growing up um I like
to think so
but it's always been like where I love
him and that's how he expresses love yes
it's with hate exactly what's the worst
good it seems like you guys prank each
other seems like you guys kind of [ __ ]
around with each other yeah has there
been something that's gone too far
um I I think it always stops before it
gets too far okay I've wanted to do oh
there's this one that I wanted to do but
it got cut it was a I wanted to throw
rent out a club and have every girl he's
ever hooked up with because he went on a
rampage that's a goodbye video to him
going away for college Wow
yeah call it closure club yeah that's
[ __ ] nuts yeah I got stopped because
it didn't the girls were there like all
you need to think about the girls and
like yeah but they don't have to comment
[Laughter]
Oh does he know that that was in the
word yeah okay what's he think about
that in front of his friends he's like I
open and care and then off like one we
were I was like I would have [ __ ]
killed ya that I can't even imagine but
I also really want it to happen yeah I
think it's it should not be an idea that
gets thrown away completely don't know
I'll be working on yeah so he goes to
school yes he's in college now yeah
University
whatever Canada University yes what's he
study um I think he's just switching it
around he doesn't really know I think
it's psychology okay cool yeah I mean
that's helpful does he because it seems
like you bring your family into your
videos a lot does he want to be like
social media YouTube digital not at all
no like he just isn't like the work that
goes into it he likes money okay so he
can be a youtuber that's basically what
youtubers are I don't know he isn't like
I don't know he likes free stuff and
money so like I don't know like whenever
we he doesn't like putting effort into
anything so like he whenever he does
videos for me
or like when I do a prank on him like I
am forced to actually give him
compensation oh yeah like it's my mum
enforces this so you have an actual
business relationship with your brother
only him everyone else does it for free
yeah that's so I can you have a sister
too right yes but is she not as
frequently in the videos um she's just
too nice okay to explain like yeah cuz I
did one prank on her um
I legally married her boyfriend yes I
asked I have this in my notes you could
tell us about this what is this yeah so
this is like riding off of my coming out
video yeah and my coming have any went
viral and so I felt like this pressure
to like do something insane right um and
so I think someone said jokingly all you
should get married I was like that's
brilliant
so I was like who would be dumb enough
to marry me and like my sister's
boyfriend we're like he was trying to do
YouTube as well I was just like this
would do super well he can't fake it I'm
like I agree so we in 24 hours we went
to Vegas from Canada sure in the morning
and then got married and went back home
and then okay what was the chapel like
um it was like they were really confused
because we didn't want to say it was for
like a YouTube video yeah you're like we
need to film it ourselves like we have a
package I'm like no no no like can I pay
to like mm-hmm and they were really
confused by we wouldn't like kiss or do
any really fist bumps like it was like
now you may kiss the bride that's so
funny yeah and then we went back I
invited as Ted told the family um hey I
need to do a dinner I'm filming it they
came and it went really badly actually I
edited to make it look like everyone was
really happy sure the actual raw footage
everyone starts crying my mom goes I'm
never gonna be part of your videos again
exactly yeah like it went crazy Wow yeah
and now where was your sister's stance
on this well this is happening he was
actually the more lenient one oh really
yes my mom and my older sister were
really upset because they have like
they're they really value marriage sure
yeah tradition yes exactly my sister
also does but she also she's like I get
it like the YouTube game like yeah it's
[ __ ] that was this sounds like she was
just like like I understand that you
guys thought I was a joke but she was
also really hurt and but now she finds
it funny I think I don't know so wait
you guys aren't are you still married oh
no I got annulled a few months ago what
was that process like I don't know well
for a few months we didn't do anything
cuz like we just I just I just I was
procrastinating yeah my mom actually did
everything she
oshi paperwork yeah because she really
wanted it annulled Wow I know
Wow usually moms help like 19 year olds
get into colleges yeah this is a very
different mom teenage daughter moment
Wow does your family since then have
they developed any sort of like safe
word in which they say to you stop this
I feel like I personally learned those
boundaries
I just know like maybe nothing legal
would yeah
smart um the only person I is my brother
like there's there's certain exes I'm
not allowed to discuss or bring on
always give him out you have to give the
family a heads-up I don't tell them what
the video is just that I'm filming a
video gotcha gotcha so they're just like
certain rules I mean that is kind of
like you know traditional TV making it's
like letting everyone know that cameras
will be rolling yeah and so they are now
legally on camera mm-hmm that's very
very funny
okay let's talk about Dodie and Corinna
what does this love triangle
what well cos Dodie it was the the muse
behind your coming-out yes yeah so she
was the girl that really kind of tipped
you over the edge
yeah yeah yes did she know yeah well she
knew cuz I kept on making little videos
about it painfully obvious do you left a
trail of breadcrumbs yeah like for
example making a video called I do my
crush a prong both of us never talking
about the title and just like really
brushing through a her a prom yeah yeah
and so it was like something we both
knew and then I think I made a video
called confessing my feelings to my
crush mm-hmm and I it was a video
explaining that I did have a crush and
like I got over it and then I sent that
video link to her oh wow and then that's
how we talked about it yeah Wow okay so
then what's the Corinna of it ah um
Corinna was my first kiss really filmed
a video called my first kiss oh I saw
the thumb now I didn't know if that was
like a click
no no those real well yeah and people
have just like kind of been like oh I
want help with granola Ella Dodie and
that's just been it but neither one want
to be with me triangle yeah is the fan
base is split down the middle I guess
it's just whoever was a fan of Dodi
beforehand and whoever's fan of crema
cuz I don't see people who watch david
dobrik watching Dodi as well yeah that's
very true those seem like two different
television networks yes to different
types of people for sure yeah
were you just in London yeah what were
you doing there just bopping around I
think it was filming a video the video
where I interview Dodi oh right right
right yeah and uh it was like one my one
year anniversary of being out mm-hmm I'm
actually going back in like two weeks
nice VidCon London fun yeah how okay so
in filming that video I did see it was
there a lot of unused footage or did you
end up using most of it oh the Dodie
it was 45 minutes long Wow both of us
hammered and I felt really weird because
there is the girl who is Jeju we got a
fan of Dodie to draw a Dodie okay to do
a big draw a Dodie stick around and it
was like 11 a.m. and I was pounding back
like oh my god cuz I was like I'm like I
can't do this yeah of course not and
then Jody walks in and she's like uh
meets the girl and I'd always like are
you drinking I was like yeah shake me to
start me were like what does this girl
think of us yeah 11:00 a.m. anyway but
uh yeah I was like it's like closure
because we never talked about it was
just something that's always been public
right neither of us have ever had like a
one-on-one conversation about exactly
yeah with a camera yeah a very healthy
millennial way of communicating always
be filming exactly
that's so but you guys are like friends
now right yeah she's like one of my
closest friends yeah that's awesome
what's been the response from your
audience like the to that and like the
coming out video like I'm sure you get a
lot of messages of people just really
relating and being like inspired by that
yeah have you gotten like an
overwhelming that yeah like um coming
that coming-out experience was really
crazy for me cuz like that was my way
actually I have this unhealthy thing
where I use my videos to talk to people
in my real life so that was my way of
coming out to my family and friends
actually yeah just posting that video so
it was like killing a bunch of birds
with one stone yeah and so like
immediately like it was just really
overwhelming and I knew that I was gonna
get positive reactions online just cuz
did you know the whole time they were
filming it that you were definitely
gonna post it or did you ever have a
moment that you were like I don't know
if I'm actually gonna like this is good
for me that it's helping me talk to my
family and stuff that I don't know if
I'm gonna use this I knew I was gonna
post it like but like I had like a lot
of like oh my god this is all right like
it was really interesting really nervous
yeah like it was a lot of stress
building up to it but I had always known
I'm like but I want effort into this
yeah what was it like when you clicked
like public on the video did you
immediately he's really high my heart
rate I would throw my computer out the
window yeah laughter I don't really I
feel like I blocked blacked out yeah I
don't really remember that day too well
no well I remember hurting like phret
friends calling like right away be like
you're gay well bye but um and then my
my sister was pretty upset because she
wanted to find out this is a running
theme with your sisters person in the
world but yeah she was a she's just like
she was she had found out before gotcha
gotcha
understandable but sure that's so
interesting okay we're gonna take a
quick break when we get back I have a
bunch more questions for you and then we
have twitter is really [ __ ] going
nuts about stuff they want to know about
yours okay really into that too so we'll
be right back with Elle Mills on not too
deep
[Music]
to this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by lisa lisa believes
that a bed is more than just a place to
sleep it's a place for relaxation and
rest and they believe that every body
has the right to rest and that's why
they make to awsome mattresses plus
accessories and bases to give your body
the deep rest it needs the all foam lisa
mattress is new and improved featuring
cooling LS a 200 foam for enhanced
pressure relief for side sleepers their
superior hybrid mattress is the perfect
combination of foam and spring for
pressure relief and edge to edge support
lisa's mission is to provide a better
night's sleep for everybody and from day
one
lisa set out to create a company with
heart that's why they donate one
mattress for every 10 they sell to
organizations that work in causes like
foster care prevention to date they've
donated more than 32 thousand mattresses
through more than 1,000 nonprofits one
more time they've donated more than 32
thousand mattresses through more than
1,000 nonprofits that is incredible to
me I obviously love anyone that supports
the podcast that is a company that I
believe in but more so a company that
gives back is so incredibly wonderful to
me I am anxiously and excitedly awaiting
a Lisa mattress that's getting sent to
me so you'll hear back on what I can
expect to be the greatest night sleep of
my life but also I am so so so happy to
have a company that is so actually like
proactive in giving back to our world in
our society as part of the not too deep
family so thank you Lisa mattress and
you get 15% off your entire order at
Lisa comm such grace if you use promo
code grace that's lisa l ee s a.com
slash grace promo code grace we're back
with all Mel's okay since coming on as
bisexual have you gone back and
re-examined your childhood celebrity
crushes yes yeah no Destry the Savoy
give us some
some names um should you youtube ones as
well yeah um Alexis she's all oh really
good friends too like she's all um this
is gonna be weird one Jayma Mays she was
Emma Pillsbury uncle' yeah yeah yeah I
was obsessed with her
they I mean that's a good one yeah for
sure and I love Emma Roberts oh yeah who
doesn't yeah she's a real fulltime cutie
also I love that I hope that Alexis but
see I loved her coming out was like a
tweet that she tweeted that I'm huh I
remember scrolling through and seeing it
one day and then being like
huh actual double take to be like oh
that's cool yeah it's very subtle and
very like on brand for like her
personality time exactly what has been
the world in which cuz you've been
how long you've been doing actually like
making content well I kind of been
making videos so like on different
channels like since I was in elementary
okay but like I'd say this channel like
I fully started like doing weekly 2016
gotcha yeah and what's it been like now
going to VidCon since things like that
it's insane yeah like I'd like the
biggest YouTube fangirl I'm like because
I like grew up watching YouTube right
and so like going to these things I'm
like well I've been like I watched like
VidCon vlogs like for years I was never
able to go right and like seeing people
like I fangirls when I saw you I
remember I was VidCon I was with like
Christine Cedella or someone you walk by
and you're like hi hi to Christine and I
didn't you walked away and I fell to the
ground okay probably quite an
abbreviated or wildly hungover those are
my only two functions conventions that's
the only way that I operate so I just
sort of float around now and try not to
make eye contact with anyone
yeah what's been like the coolest oh
actually what's been like the weirdest
convention moment cuz I'm sure now that
you go these things people come up to
you and you know there is that rapport
that we all have with each other where
we know each other without
really knowing each other yeah so do you
have like mmm interesting like fan
interactions fan interactions um I find
playlists very interesting with oh yeah
attractions okay um wasn't there
something where like people got into
your hotel room or something there was
or they like found where your hotel room
is someone was tweeting about it oh yeah
yeah that I know exactly what that is
Dodi and I got really drunk uh-huh and
we had a drunk Meetup okay and we made a
bucket list and one of them was to go
into a fan's hotel room okay and so ya
know um I think the weirdest one would
be like it's just like there was this
girl that was really trying to get into
my hotel room but like through my meet
up like she was like I I'm alone like my
parents left me I was like okay okay I
was like are you like maybe you should
talk to a person who works yet she's
like I don't know like they said my
dad's are they all coming to get me
tomorrow but I just need a hotel to stay
and you know how they usually had people
would like to uh sure yeah
you know there's like different types of
guys there's someone who really strict
this guy was like the fun security guys
yeah he's letting you have your time
when really you're like exactly so I was
like ten minutes of that and I ended up
getting someone and I she cut she found
me again just like I still don't have
him like I don't know what to do for you
just a hard and fast rule for anyone
going to conventions don't assume that a
content creator is gonna allow you to
sleep in their hotel yeah might just be
you know creating boundaries safe spaces
mm-hmm is there anyone that you haven't
met in the YouTube space that you're
like dying to me oh yeah kollene
ballinger oh I mean talk about God's
gift to earth yeah she really is
fantastic oh man I really want to meet
her I made her another embarrassing
fangirl story because again I'd been a
huge fan girl for so long um I she has
her dm's open it has had them open for a
while huh and I made a fan video I kept
on DMing it to her and then
she ended up DMing me like recently over
and I scrolled up I'm like oh no when
you look back at the one side the
conversation you've been having but
exactly please watch this video worked
really hard on it sigh pologize I'm so
sorry so sweet she's also just like the
kindest sweetest gentlest person so I
feel like it's impossible to embarrass
yourself in front of her yes very very
kind what is the nicest thing your
brothers ever said to you literally
today I've been negotiating with him
because he won't let me do a video like
I love that these like to like moguls
that are also siblings like sending
contracts back boy nicest thing you said
to me oh he said I was in once in high
school I wore like a Winnie the Pooh
costume to school he told his friends
that I looked cute then I called him out
and he says you're wearing I'm Winnie
the Pooh costume so obviously duh and
then he like got really defensive about
you guys some fun together yeah you were
valedictorian of your high school yes
that's [ __ ] rad Thanks what how did
the speech go I'll just be sure she went
really well
I took the roast approach so I roasted
the entire grad class okay and then I
ended it with sauce and sentimental yeah
but I think I got a standing ovation
really yeah well but I do want to
clarify I I don't do this in the States
it's a bit different I guess but but I
never correct anyone because I think it
makes me sound smart okay but in my
school Val Victorian didn't mean highest
average what did it mean it just meant
the people who who on the guy cost voted
who they wanted to do the speech oh so
you're basically prom king yeah no it
sounds impressive so I just go yeah it
was Valerie turn that's I mean honestly
I don't know why we don't do that in our
high school cuz the guy that spoke at
our or the girl spoke at my graduation
should not have done
it was a it was long and monotone and
she seemed scared yeah I would have
loved the voting situation I would kind
of touched on this but which of your
videos had the worst cleanup afterwards
oh yeah it would be the wedding the
wedding one to clean up yeah yeah
is there anything since then that your
mom is like put her foot down that's
like you cannot do this no okay I
haven't done anything not crazy okay
I was gonna change legally changed my
middle name that seems too tame
yeah - because it was when I hit a
million I was gonna be L has mils
probably wouldn't approve it's a family
name what's wrong with that I think
that's great
and also like it's only hurting yourself
exactly but nothing I haven't done
anything yeah yes there's still time
yeah exactly it's the beginning of the
year how would you propose to Corinna
versus how you think she'd proposed to
you
Corinna proposed to me I would have to
propose to Corona in a big way because
Colonel loves money and she's so
self-aware you know so it's like she
likes bougie stuff so like I would
definitely and she likes Klout so like I
just make a video out of it and that's
how I proposed to her she would
proposing to me um I don't think she
would all right yeah okay if you had to
cast one of your closer YouTube friends
to play you in a movie who would you
cast when it was like close you two
friends mm-hmm or let's say YouTube
friend to play you and then maybe a
traditional actress okay [ __ ]
I just don't think anyone would do me
justice I know I think about this for
myself and I'm like uh I think that
we've been talking about that whole day
today I think Macaulay Macaulay Culkin
Culkin because I just found out that
he'd done what he legally changed his
name yeah
so speaking of changing your name right
he legally changed it I just found out
today that I'm in love with McAuley
called yeah I've been doing some
research and yeah it's it's a strong
crush now who Oh No he's perfect
yeah he's hilarious on Twitter I had no
idea yeah sweets the incredible coke is
his name it's perfect she's perfect I
love him
so I think I'd have him play me I could
see that thank you yeah I could see it
too just screaming like I don't know for
YouTube but like traditional I always
said I would want like an unknown like a
puppet I'm okay yeah that's very future
filmmaker of yeah okay what oh okay
mmm sorry I'm just uh I saw the words
Cheesecake Factory written under stars I
got distracted
hardcore what okay let's say you're
invited to the Met Gala where the photos
of inside the bathroom where the photos
of inside the bathroom is known for
being packed with celebrities what do
you say to break the ice while waiting
for a toilet between Rihanna and Gigi
Hadid oh wow yeah
elaborate um what do I say to break the
ice between Rehanna and Gigi Hadid I
feel like I honestly would just be like
how the [ __ ] did I get yeah great wait
so how many conventions have you gone to
so far um I'm playlist DC uh-huh and
then I went just buffer fest yes
festival I think it's more like it's
different not really too much of a
convention but yeah buffer festival
playlist Orlando VidCon yep summer in
the city that's the one I haven't gone
to that I really want to go to yeah
Jackie went to that one yeah yeah I like
that one it's very I gotta get invited
to be able to cook
and then um playlist again playlist what
so now that you've like kind of
collected these conventions under your
belt what's one thing like a major thing
you've learned that like you prep now
going into these things I'm gonna be
exhausted
yeah I'm drained and tired and drunk and
then I will I will have a bad time but
for some of it and then I will forget
and then come again yeah yeah the
overarching like fun of it yeah kind of
pushes to the side I did times that were
stressful or bad mm-hmm oh that's fun I
I'm just so over it at this point that's
very very much over no I know this is
when I first because my first convention
was in 2017 and I went and I was so
excited yeah I'm like oh my god I'm
finally here I'm on the other side and
everyone was like kind of tired you
didn't over it you two friends no I'm
like I'm like I'm talked about all these
fun stories from like years back you
know what it feels like it feels like I
just came in in the wrong time I feel
like a huge hurricane happen and I just
came during the aftermath ready to party
yeah yeah I think there was a house
party that like a hurricane hit it and
then you showed up with a six-pack like
after everyone's like party's over you
come in here refreshed ready to handle
this yeah they are they're overwhelming
to say the least but still you know very
fun yeah
have you had any regretful interactions
with other content creators yes I'm
trying to think of them right now these
things these are the memories that get
repressed deep down yeah I just feel
like the first coverage I went to I went
up to a lot of people and a lot of
people didn't know who I was and so like
I don't want to name in you don't worry
yeah but some some of them were just
like I can tell they're like who the
[ __ ] are you
but then the honestly all those people
have like I've met them again
nicer yeah that's good I know the first
time I met Harley Morenstein
I wasn't even like I was like starting
to make videos and I went up to him at a
party and he was like full drunk sauce
boss I think it was a party for Epic
Meal Time at the time and I went up with
him I could see in Hanover good friends
and I had met him like once before and I
thought I was gonna be cool by being
like he was like who are you and I'm
like we've met before and he's like I
don't know who the [ __ ] you are and I
was like oh ok nevermind no yeah and
then I met him later again and I told
him that he did that and he was very
sorry I'm just like I think you were
just in your full Harley mode yeah which
you know to be fair was a great initial
impression of the sauce boss yes at that
time okay we have a billion Twitter
questions that I really want to get into
because a lot of them are really really
great so we're gonna take another quick
break and then be right back with your
questions for Elle has Mills
[Music]
this episode of not too deep is brought
to you by thread up do you want to save
money save the planet and look good
doing it it doesn't get any better then
thread up thread up is the largest
online consignment store where you can
shop high-quality pieces for up to 90%
off estimated retail they have over
35,000 brands ranging from Gap to Gucci
with thousands of new items added every
day and you can find a coach purse for
$10 an anthropology dress for $6 a
Lululemon tank for $10 what else could
you need if you go to thredUP comm slash
grace today you'll get an extra 30% off
your first order it's super easy and fun
to shop save your sizes your favorite
brands and filter for exactly what you
want it's the comfort of shopping online
with the insane deals of thrifting look
good and do good this year with thredUP
go to thredUP comm slash grace for an
extra 30% off your first order that's th
our edu p.com slash grace thredUP comm
slash grace for an extra 30% off today
terms apply
oh we're back and we're gonna get into
the Twitter questions but before we do
I'm gonna ask you the two questions that
I ask every single guess it's on the
podcast yeah and the first is who alive
or dead would you most want to throw
cold spaghetti at Oh hmm cold spaghetti
I would like to throw cold spaghetti
that's too obvious I love it you're
having a full dialogue in your head
right I'm gonna say like Jake problem I
was like no oh yeah that's too boring oh
how do you see his name my cold Macaulay
Culkin yeah yeah yeah he'll scream
we'll get that we'll get the home alone
face okay the other question I ask every
guest is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story or close call me you can
only use three words or three small
phrases so mine is college jogging front
lawn okay mmm-hmm mine is fart reunion
oh okay China oh okay
paint the picture no follow up questions
there okay here are these Twitter
questions
let's get into them someone to know what
is the best slash worst experience
you've had with religion in correlation
with your sexuality oh wow
did you grow up religious um mm-hmm
there's fitment family members that are
very really just sure um honestly no bad
things it's just not talked about yeah
almost like there that's why I didn't
talk tell my sister mm because her mom
is very religious laughter got to go and
so not I just did I was just
appreciating her the way she grew up in
like a certain way and with certain
morals that's why I was unsure of where
she stood got your never talked about it
sure yeah well I think that's respectful
there's good intentions there yeah
someone to know what's your advice for
people who are afraid to
come out Wow um I'd say first of all
don't feel pressure to you don't need to
yeah yeah you owe no one nothing but
only do it when you're ready and I feel
like you'll know when you're ready yeah
like you'll have this feeling you're
like okay I could I'll do it and I'd
have a camera exactly
document have a register YouTube channel
yes and then figure it out someone's you
know what do you put on your hot dog oh
um ketchup mustard and relish oh when
you're here in the States what do you
miss most about Canada put in that's how
you say it yeah Putin Putin not poutine
that's it's wrong it's because you're if
you ask anyone that's not from Quebec or
Ottawa you're gonna hear poutine okay
it's a french-canadian dish it's called
Putin right right right where's the best
place to get it when you go home um I'm
not picky honestly because you can get
it like as a side like if you go to
McDonald's you might decide of the ten
really McDonald cells but ten yeah yeah
someone's no what's your favorite Dodie
song oh wow I always used to say would
you be so kind she hates that song oh
really
hates it but you just went what's you
performing recently yeah yeah yeah I'll
pick a song for offering you a P to give
her that promo get that I'm gonna go
with if I'm being honest cool yeah it's
really good her new what's it called
human yeah is that her new EP that just
came in yeah I haven't sat down and
listened to all of it really good yeah
I've hear her little snippets on her
Instagram story mm-hmm by the way do you
have a preferred social media platform
they use um I have a special place in my
heart for Twitter really yeah
oh that's interesting why do you think
that is so many people that I've talked
to recently I just over Twitter yeah
because that's where I initially grew my
audience oh I used to post my videos
straight to Twitter really and that's
how I gained an audience yeah whoa cool
why did you do that I just wanted more
exposure I felt like posting the link
people are less likely to go over
yeah yeah is there one Twitter or one
social media platform that you wish
would burn to the ground
um I mean like snapchat mmm I don't use
it it's still on my phone I clicked it
by accident the other day and I felt
like exposed yeah what is this Oh No get
it away yeah I don't know what they're
doing but it's not my favorite either
someone's no has she been able to find a
hobby
no with dodi's manager Josh I they find
it fascinating that I just don't care
enough and I don't have any hobbies and
what you do you spray down I'm like I
just sit and do nothing like and then
they're like okay we need to find your
hobby so we have like we do this like
this just podcast on the side uh-huh
calltell tries and tried to find me a
hobby I've yet to find one what have you
tried so far
I'll try is baking ghost hunting oh I
don't know I do you watch TV um like a
bit okay but it's not like that's not a
hobby no yeah I just don't and also
don't disturb the attention span it's
just it's very weird I just don't I
wonder if that's because you grew up
with a YouTube you know being your
primary source of like entertainment so
your attention span is conditioned to
like five minutes max yeah is there
anyone that you're like currently
obsessed with on YouTube um you think is
making like interesting content um I
obviously liked a lot of david dobrik i
really like Luke corns
yeah his videos are so good I always
tell him like he's so good and I just
feel like he needs more expect like yeah
what people need to watch his videos he
and Mikey Murphy right yeah they were
like started together or something yeah
they have similar fan bases yeah yeah I
remember them
Mikey Murphy wasn't dirty 30 with us and
he he's just like this little artists
like walking her and I was like this is
like a baby boy but he's also like got a
great aesthetic eye that I was like so
jealous
I haven't caught up with them and to go
back and see what they're up to
I'm supposed to know what's your
favorite thing about growing up in
Ottawa oh I like how boring it is really
it's like nothing happens and it's like
all of us kind of make fun of that yeah
how would you describe Ottawa to someone
like to an alien it's an alien yeah like
just nothing nothing going on doesn't
change okay yeah just like home the same
thing yeah just like kind of okay with
being exactly what it is exactly yeah
yeah yeah that's very refreshing that's
sweet
so let's know what cartoon character
would you want to hang out with
I would like to hang out with Stewie
oh that's a good one yeah I kept going
back to like old Nickelodeon era yeah
cartoons there's a spongebob was like no
yeah he seemed like he'd get a little
annoying
exactly quickly and then you and a
little clingy mm-hmm so I think you're
making it so take like the babies are
someone to know a lot of people ask this
question what's your favorite video that
you've ever made
oh I'm lucky that my top three most
popular like my talk to be favorite oh
yeah yeah um but I'm gonna go with my
first kiss okay very cool yeah what's
like um what what's your creative like
motivation going into this year like do
you have kind of like a plan of action
of how you want to make videos or the
style of videos you want to make or you
just kind of like playing it by ear yeah
I I realize I'm not gonna force a video
because I there's a couple like last
year where I'm like oh I need a video
let's do something crazy and they ended
up not doing well anyway or like I
wasn't happy with how the end product
look sure and so like if it comes
naturally then I'm gonna do it and uh
yeah that's my main mode I think that's
super smart cuz I feel like when you
took that kind of mental health break
like you said that YouTube when you tear
like parading you around as the poster
child is that once you actually like
give yourself permission to take a break
and you realize it's not the scariest
thing in the world and it's not like
ending your
you know forward momentum yeah that I
think you start to develop more like
leniency with yourself to take breaks
and like not force things um so I I'm
glad that you're kind of being a poster
child I'm glad that you're forced into
the poster child
someone's know what's your best or
weirdest childhood memory um oh gosh
weirdest I peed my pants a lot as a kid
okay like like think of like anxiety you
know I always had when I laughed you
hard
I often peed my pants okay and I it went
up to like like not like maybe a little
too old like 15 16 Oh going strong those
are weird childhood memories oh my god I
was gonna say yeah I haven't peed my
pants since 15 but she peed my pants at
playlist why like I tell this story and
every time it always gets bad reactions
and it's always like like uncomfortable
watching so I'm preparing for this okay
I tell you it was the drunk Meetup and I
had this planned sober yeah like pure
thing all she was so drunk she piss
their pants I was like I'm gonna its
that playlist wasn't fun yeah me so I
was like I'm gonna end it off by peeing
my pants on purpose the obvious choice
when you're not having fun party just
let it go I was like I bet you like I'm
gonna do it they're like oh no you're
not gonna do it so we did the fan meetup
and I did it in front of everyone oh my
god there's like footage of this oh yeah
yeah video happened like two days later
really they weren't correlated that was
just my people are like they were clear
sign yeah they were flags publicly
urinating on yourself
someone help her well that's fun and
then you know this year I can only
imagine what you have planned for the
end of play
someone to know if you could be in any
musical or Broadway production what
would it be
High School Musical 3 whoa
you had that locked and loaded I love
that movie I haven't seen the first two
I know I'm very non cultured to you man
I know
are you musical are you do saying no I
wish yeah it's like if I could have a
superpower I think you'd be singing
exactly
someone's know what Canadian question or
Canadian stereotype do you hear the most
when you're in the States
Oh a lot of people point out when I say
A Okay and O in my pronunciation of like
big spell it be a G oh my god I was like
she's mispronouncing something but I
don't know what the bag that's a bag we
say bag bag I don't know I feel like
whenever I'm with Christine so Delco
it's just constant it's like do you have
that in Canada yeah how did you guys
meet each other you're a very funny duo
am i oh yeah yeah we we both got a lot
of heat on Twitter at the same time
really yeah 20:17 for what being quirky
for having a personality or like step it
down yeah no people were just really
annoyed of our humor and like food jokes
and stuff I love it that's what you get
hateful yeah we have like some brothers
that run around being actually trash and
enough of it
someone must know what do you do to
overcome a funk oh god um I I don't know
I like to do stuff that makes me feel
better yeah maybe like partying yeah
you're going out to your favorite
restaurant mm-hmm do you consider
because I I know like as youtubers
there's a big kind of like blanketed
stereotype that we're all like
introverts and like don't know how to
socialize with each other do you
consider yourself an introvert or
extrovert um
what's the pathway the inter I think I'm
pretty social and everything but I do
like my a long time but I wouldn't say
I'm an introvert at all okay yeah that's
cool
someone's to know if there was an
alternate universe what did you what do
you think alternate L would be like Oh
what has changed in this alternate
universe I don't know if I wasn't doing
YouTube maybe yeah what would you do
like would what are your career thoughts
you know if YouTube didn't exist I think
I would be in school still before I was
in business marketing you were yeah
probably doing like just probably
following my dad's footsteps really like
that yeah Oh interesting what does he do
um he's the CFO of the Red Cross Wow
yeah that's pretty easy job that's very
my brother works at the Red Cross in
Philadelphia so I'll have to tell him I
met basically the daughter of his boss
someone to know what's the hardest thing
you've ever been through and what have
you learned from that situation
oh um probably the hardest thing I've
been through is that huge burnout
breakdown yeah back in April May cuz how
long did you actually take off
well when three weeks yeah yeah because
I had like commitments like buffer LA
and that's when I made so I made burnt
out at 19 and then immediately after I
had promised VidCon I was gonna premiere
video okay I spent a month working on
that gotcha but yeah I mean like I just
took longer periods I was I was pumping
out like a video once a week to maybe
like that was like a big difference yeah
do you edit all of your videos or so
yeah oh wow I mean that's yeah that's a
lot of work because how long does it
take you on average to edit one of those
like like I would say 48 hours dang yeah
Wow I had to start caring about my work
[Laughter]
I can't yeah whoo all right very cool
very cool someone to note what's the
wildest dream you've had about your
crush have too many crushes to be fair
just without saying Dodie um I don't um
ya know I didn't really have it too many
Co best worst parts of having a Filipino
mom Oh a hot Filipino I'm sorry I mean
Google your mom putting it all out there
is like best is definitely the Filipino
party's like really know Filipino mom's
like love like karaoke really yeah it's
like interests I don't think I've ever
heard that before yeah okay what's your
what's your go-to karaoke song what your
mom's go-to karaoke song my mom's I
think it's crazy for you by Madonna I
want her to be my best friend
so I want to be my wing woman I just
want to hang out with it yeah oh you
know that and I Will Survive she was she
loves us too
I I'm gonna go with crazy for you I took
that up okay there you go
like it's all in the family now exactly
that's so funny
okay here's our last question and then
we have a parting gift for you for
making time while you're in town to be
on the podcast someone wants to know who
or what inspires you as a creator
um what inspires me who inspires me
baby's probably better I I don't know I
look at other creators and see like
those who are like really pushing it
yeah like James Charles is killing it's
amazing yeah and I'm like I see that I'm
like I'm inspired to like keep going
like sometimes I'm just like I want to
sleep instead yeah
I'm seeing the like seeing like people
really succeed and like make the
transition from like digital to
traditional and like just killing the
game I guess that's what really inspires
me
I mean that's a very honest authentic
answer thank you
we've reached on the podcast but before
we go we have a parting gift for you
like I said no it's a personalized
fortune cookie
oh that you're welcome to open and read
the fortune okay which please open it
and read the fortune I can't eat the
cookie yeah edible 2019 will be the
battle for Elle Mills is Hart quranic'
off vs. Eliza Koshi vs. Dodie Clark but
I'll just end in hugs and compliments in
the bathroom while waiting to pee lame
lame thing that's the most inaccurate
about that fortune is a you're not gonna
pee in the bathroom can people find you
and what you're up to if they don't
already know yeah on YouTube youtube.com
slash Sheldon Mills Twitter is at Nils L
and an Instagram into L dot Mills
awesome I'm so excited to watch what
happens whatever the [ __ ] happens for
you this year
so thank you again for being here and
making time and good luck with
everything
thank you of course we'll see you guys
next time on not too deep goodbye 2deep
2deep 2deep 2deep
again this episode of not too deep was
brought you by thredUP want to save
money save the planet and look good
doing it it does not get any better than
thredUP
it's the largest online consignment and
thrift store shop over 35,000 brands and
up to 90% off estimated retail go to
thredUP calm slash grace for an extra
30% off your first order that's th re
DUP calm slash grace gr AC e thread up
comm such grace for an extra 30% off
today
[Music]